if you have a significant experience  during a day you're gonna dream about it  the same night and Michelle's dream is a  perfect example of that residue because  she incorporated a lot of different  elements of the laboratory in her dream  there is all sorts of machinery moving  around early in newer leaves of the cat  running to grow all sensory modalities  can be present in the dreams they can be  very particular bodily sensations when  somebody's flying in the dream actually  Michelle was describing yesterday I was  flying like a dolphin it was a very  particular very clear in her in her mind  sensation of flying in a particular way  so she actually had a pretty clear and  pretty obvious de residue